All right. You know what the topic is,
right, King David?
>> Yeah, I know. It's um is Jesus God?
>> Most High God. Yes. You heard the
evidence and you heard the arguments.
So, what are you?
>> Yeah, I'm an Israelite. So, I see you
did a little something with Tesaria um
on this topic.
>> A little something. Did you hear the
arguments that I just spent and in the
other sessions that he's the most high,
especially from Hebrews 1, or you just
jumping in the middle without even
knowing what the arguments are?
>> Well, I've been watching you for a
while, but I haven't um
>> I haven't seen this that you're doing
now.
>> All right, that's good.
>> But I saw your arguments with Tesarak
with Hebrews, too, as well.
>> Obviously, you didn't like his
performance. That's why you're here. So,
what's up? What's your questions?
I mean, uh, his performance was all
right, but I feel like you had stronger
po you had stronger points when it came
to scripture. For sure.
>> Yeah. He didn't have any good arguments
from scripture. It's all just going on a
lengthy
diet [clears throat] tribe, dulling out
meat to his fan base and saying, "Oh,
you're talking over me because someone
told me his strategy would be to try to
insult me in order to get me to react."
What?
>> Exactly. And he Exactly. And you're not
going to win that way with insults
because you just deflecting from the
main point. And he went to
>> Yep. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. You remember when he went to Where
did he go? He went to Samuels with the
um whole Elohim
>> 1st Samuel 24:8 which is Adoni. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And I I feel like that really that
blew him right there for real because
you showed the Hebrew. It was on the
screen. It's right there in everybody's
face.
>> 192,000 views thus far. And Cameron says
the most viewed debate. But yeah. So, if
you're an Israelite, I hope you worship
the Trinity. Do you worship the Trinity?
>> Well, the way y'all explain it, I'm
trying to comprehend it and get it. But
to be honest, I feel like y'all both are
kind of saying the same thing because it
goes to this it goes to this different
person's type thing, right? Like three
persons, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But he doesn't think Jesus is the most
high. He thinks he's a created God.
>> Yeah. So when y'all say the most high,
y'all saying like the same essence
though, but it's still three different
persons, right?
>> Precisely. He keeps thinking the father
alone is the most high. Whereas I was
trying to show him that Jesus is
identified as the most high and yet he's
not the father.
>> Right. And I feel like that's I feel
like why can't he wrap his head around
that? Cuz that's basically I feel like
he's trying to say that but he's making
this creation thing like oh he's a
created being. When you go to John 1
and1, Jesus is the word of God and it's
like it says the word was God and it was
there from the beginning. So, how can it
be created? You know what I mean?
>> I I really don't know what he believes
anymore. At one time I thought that he
thought Jesus is just a man, but then he
says Jesus has a pre-existence.
I don't know if he changed his position
because I heard him in the past saying
Jesus is a man. Then he says Christ has
a pre-existence. So now is he what we
call [clears throat] an Aryan? Meaning
like Aras thinks that Christ was created
as a secondary God. So I don't I don't
even know what he believes because I
know not all Israelites have the same
belief about God.
>> What's your belief about the Trinity?
>> I feel like I'm more on your side. So So
the way the way you put it is very, you
know, you can comprehend it. It makes
sense and I feel like it's more in line
with the scripture. You know what I'm
saying?
>> Embrace.
Yeah, I mean, hey, it is what it is, but
I just feel like when it comes to the
Israelites and with you and this, you
know, this back and forth, I would
really
>> I'm sorry. Yeah,
>> it's only the beef is only with him. I
don't I don't beef with Israelites. In
fact, I was in a debate in
[clears throat] Hebrew Israelite
congregation where the people there
did not believe exactly like the Zarak.
They didn't think are going to
be slaves, etc. But you'll see it
online. This was when I was in Chicago.
So,
>> was it when you was sitting down at a
table?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> With your boys. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I
peeped that, too. And I seen one when
you was um you pulled up on them when
they was outside street preaching as
well. It was a grip ago.
>> Yeah. That one was We couldn't hear.
Here it is. Here it is, guys. Psalm 23
has it 46K. This is when I was still in
Chicago Shike Town.
>> So, he has it on his channel.
>> So, right here I was with Joe Wyrostic.
I was still in my Protestantism. Now,
these guys don't believe exactly like
Kazarak. They have a different view. So,
if you guys want to see this, here's the
link. But nonetheless, since you're a
Trinitarian man, just keep studying
because if you keep studying, I think
you'll eventually, you know, find your
way into the ancient churches because
you don't have a beef with me at the
Trinity then.
>> No, I don't. I just feel like um what
you doing, the work you've been putting
in, it's amazing, bro. And when I watch
you and I I see the way you work, it's
really something that's um inspiring.
And of course, it's all praises to the
Most High. I'm not trying to
triune.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm not trying to big you up
because I know that you work through the
power of the most high.
>> So just the knowledge you have and the
way you able to pull that up and the
things you do, it's got to be the most
high. And even though we might not
believe the exact same things, we might
not have the exact same doctrine, I do
recognize when the Most High is working
with somebody. So, I just wanted to say
that for you, bro.
>> And um just as well, I would love to see
um maybe you not debating the doctrine
of the Israelites because like you said,
they have many, many doctrines, bro, and
a lot of it is notating them. But I
would like for you to I don't know if
you agree or not, but I would like for
you to
>> maybe debate what every Israelite
believes, which is that, you know, the
descendants of the transatlantic slave
trade are the biblical descendants of
the um of the Jews.
>> So, I don't know if you agree with that
or not, but
>> it just seems like a lot of times
doctrine of the Israelites is being
debated, but what we all share is never
being debated. And um yeah, I just like
to see maybe if um you can do something
on that.
>> Maybe because King David my my forte has
been trinitarianism.
Meaning when I came back to my Christian
roots
>> Oh, I'm I'm sorry, Sam. Um I can't I
can't hear you. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can I can hear you, but you
can't hear me.
>> Okay, my bad. It's It must be something
on my end, but I'll I'll just drop and
join back in if you don't mind. I'll
answer I'll answer that. All right,
cool. Cool, bro. All right. Peace.
All right. Well, hey guys, did you hear
it? A Hebrew Israelite. Did you hear it?
Jeremy Wong, everyone, did you hear it?
Hebrew Israelite just acknowledged the
most high whom he now acknowledges as
the triune God. He admits the most high
is the trinity. And he admits that he
cannot deny that the most high is
working through me.
Now that is a praise that we glorify the
father, the son, the lord Jesus Christ
and the holy spirit for. Glory to the
triune God. Glory to the father. Glory
to the lord Jesus Christ. Glory to the
holy spirit. Even in Hebrewism I just
acknowledge I cannot deny that the most
high is working through you because your
stuff is amazing. Glory to the lord
Jesus Christ. Okay. Now king just to
leave you what I was about to say. You
ready?
>> Yes sir. Yep.
>> The reason why I haven't gotten into the
issue of the slave trade and whether
when I say black obviously I mean those
Hebrews that are not Anglo-Saxon because
you are aware there are white folks who
say they're the Israelites because the
nine and a half tribes crossed over the
Caucus Mountains settled in Europe and
that the Britishers are the Israelites.
So you have two camps that argue they're
the true Israelites.
>> Yeah. I've seen that. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And so the reason why I didn't get into
that because when I returned to my
Christian roots,
what was of primary concern for me was
the Godhead, the nature of God, because
I had Muslims, Jehovah's Witnesses
telling me there was no trinity.
>> So I can either be blessed by God to be
an expert in these areas or I can be a
jack of all trades and not even a master
of one.
>> Gotcha.
>> That's not my field. My field is I will
deal with anyone that questions the
trinity. If desire can never brought up
the issue of the trinity. I would have
no beef with him, you know, to each his
own because there are others. And the
one who's most popular, I don't know if
he's the most knowledgeable, you would
know that that deals with this issue is
Vocab Malone. That's his forte.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> That's him. So I can't get involved in
every viewpoint. I don't have the time
and I'm not young. M. So, but
>> doing it a while. You've been doing a
while, bro. I seen you when you was
looking much younger. I ain't saying you
looking old now, but I'm just saying
like you been you've been in the game
for a while. But, um,
>> 1999, God put on my heart to do
full-time ministry.
>> I was just I was just nine years old
then, man. It's crazy.
>> See, but what I want you to do now is
just study my material on the Trinity,
make it your own, and at least
acknowledge and worship and love the
triune God.
>> All right. I appreciate that. I'll just
um if I could just say I would like your
viewers to know that all Hebrew
Israelites are not the same. Just like
you said, we don't hold the same
doctrine. Obviously, when you read the
Bible, anybody can make it into the
kingdom. That's very obvious. So, the
way that these people are twisting it,
it's not a representation of all of us.
We accept everybody. You know what I'm
saying? That's perfectly fine. But we
can't we can't miss out on who the
people are because when you do that,
you're missing out on so much prophecy
in the Old Testament. And we know um you
know in the Old Testament that the
children of Israel will come back to who
they are in the land of their captivity.
And that prophecy is being fulfilled
right now through us.
>> So I would just like
>> these individuals believe the same thing
like you. They don't believe that non
>> what they would call Israelites
>> go to hell. So they had the same belief
you did, but they didn't believe in the
Trinity.
>> Okay, I got you. I got you. And I
respect that you were saying.
>> Yeah, I respect that you saying that
it's not your field because a lot of
people wouldn't even say that. So now I
appreciate that. And you know what I'm
saying? Just whoever is listening maybe
just look into it and just understand
that we all not feel a hate and we all
not on with Tesarak is on. You know what
I'm saying?
>> No, exactly.
doesn't represent all like I said guys
these individuals
>> don't think that non-Israelites
>> go to hell that they're saved too these
individuals but they don't believe in
trinity now you have a man who believes
like them that not non-Israelites go to
hell but he worships the trinity so hey
glory to God keep studying brother keep
studying
>> yeah I app I appreciate that I'm in the
I'm in the UK I'm American but I'm in
the UK you know that you know the Muslim
influence out here so y'all been y'all
really been holding it down when it
comes [laughter]
Y'all been holding it down when it comes
to the to the Muslims out here and you
guys are really um showing these people
what it's really about. So nah, we
appreciate you, bro. Keep it up.
>> The material destroying Islam and
glorifying the Trinity and it's yours.
So use it, brother.
>> Off rip. All right, bro. Shalom, man.
>> Shalom. God bless you.
>> All right.
>> See, there you go. What else do you guys
want? I can be a jack of all trades,
master not even one, or I can be a jack
of all trades and a master of one. or I
can be a master of few subjects and
that's it. But what a blessing, what a
privilege, what an honor that an Hebrew
Israelite acknowledges the most high is
the trinity. Jesus is the most high one
with the father and the holy spirit and
that he can see the most high works
through me and has blessed me to glorify
the lord Jesus Christ. Thank you,
father, son spirit, keep me humble and
pure. Save me from backlash and slander.